こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです！
ではエンディング発表会 後半 いってみましょう
前半ではなかなか激しいやつとかクオリティ高いやつがあったんですけども、
後半の
ほんとにラスト2000代とかもう
ほぼすっげえクオリティのやつが連発して
ちょっとビビったんですけども
まあちょっとのんびり見ていきましょう！
みんな！
準備はいいか？
では行こう！！
俺じゃねえww
かわいいに尽きる
お！
いいね！
のんびりしてていいと思います、こういうのも！
うぅ…
なんか、、、いやなことでもあった？？
俺でよければ相談に乗るよ
採用
嘘です
やめろやめろやめろ！
黒歴史だー！やめろー
あーいいと思う。ステキステキ！
どんどい行きますよ！
うーーーーわ、すげぇぇなこれとか…
うわぁぁぁ
もうここまでいくとすごいんすよね
おい
歯　歯　歯　歯が出てるよー
これすごいんですよ
あの、俺の初めて住んでた部屋
次住んでた部屋
これ今までの歴代の部屋なんですよ全部
これが今住んでる部屋
これを3Dでやっちゃうっていうね
うおおおすごい
ゲーム感が、ファミコン感がある
うわあすごい
MOTHER2のテレポート使って失敗した時の黒くなった時のあれです
次
？( ^)o(^ )？
え？
あーーーあー
*不穏な音楽*
あら、うあー
ダークネスが
俺の金髪の時のと思ったら所沢が出てきて
ハンマーで叩き割って
俺だぁ
いやーもうすいません
後半はただただすごい動画が続きます
こんな感じでいきますよ
いや、すごいよ
モノクロで
飛んでくんか（咳）
不採用
なになになに怖い怖い怖い怖い
何何ー
何何何何これ
ただのホラーじゃん
次いきましょう
何これ
かっこいい
うおおおすげー
オシャレだなそして
個人的になんですけど整っててすごい好きでしたね
何なのこの煽る圧迫感のあるBGM
アイコンよく見たらオレじゃない？ポンヤン君
ポンヤン君これ俺でしょう
くそーー、、、ありがとう
不採用
おおおかっこいい
すげーすげー
すごい、イラストが可愛い
モヤッター、Moyasi+、Moyabook　おい！
全部もやしじゃん
クオリティ高いですからね
おらー来たーすごいの
Fen
ワ二ブンじゃん
おーすげー
さすがワニブンちゃん
さーどんどんいきますよ、後半戦ですよ
おーピントが合ってきた
おお
おーい！！
笑
¡¡( ^)o(^ )!!
無駄に長い成長日記動画
*中二病時代突入*
1分28秒もあるのね
最後だけ気になるので最後だけ見ようか
死んだの！？
口が動いてる
誰ー？
おっ！
あー燃えちゃった
あらららら
( ^)o(^ ）ﾌﾞﾝﾌﾞﾝﾊﾛｰYouTube
HIKA〇IN集
おいおいやめろよ親分をそんなことするんじゃない
まじで怒られるってねーやめてー
俺のエンディングじゃないでしょ
Next
所沢だ
こんにちは、所沢です
皆チ〇コ好きね
おっおっー走ってる走ってる走ってる
俺が走ってるよ、すごい
めっちゃ可愛いんですけど
これ好きかも
わー可愛い
すげー、イラストがかなり補正されてますね
これもすごいなー
すごいよ
あ、アイコンがMOTHER2バージョンのはじめだ
YouTube～♪YouTube～♪
これ違うでしょ、俺じゃないよねー
おお何ー3やばいやばいよこれは
所沢がなんかすごいな
う～～～～～わ
やばいよ
うわ、チャリ乗ってる
可愛い
えええええええ
うわ、かっけーなまた
これはオイラが好きな人だ
うおおすげー
瑞々しい
いよいよ最後の方です
動画内音声（まだチャンネル登録してない人がいるのか）
動画内音声（うっうっ！）
動画内音声（早く、チャンネル登録頼む）
動画内音声（う。おお）
開いた口が塞がらないというのはこういうことなのだろうか（バックグラウンドで少年時代/井上陽水　が流れている）
おおーでもすごい
素敵だーありがとうございます北の打ち師さん
*はじめの〇狂*
うわーーきもいきもいきもい
wwwwwwwww
やめとけやｗ
おお歩いてる歩いてる
おお可愛い
可愛い
うん
おいおいおいおい
ば、ば、ば、バカ、ちんこしゃちょーじゃねぇわ　やめとけや
家石田さん
（つまんねー人生送ってる愚民共よ）
（さっさと糞して寝ろ）
おえふふぃｓだうｄｗ
はいというわけでエンディング全部見終わりました
本当にお疲れ様でした、ありがとうございました
これ以外にも本当に沢山のエンディングを作ってくれました
気楽に作ってくれたんだなーっていうのもあるし
すごい、時間かけてやってくれたんだなーって思ったのもあったし